hey youtubers is Charlie so this week's
episode of Doctor Who totally melted my
face off it's gonna go down as one of
the best in series eight as well as like
one of the best scary fun episodes
overall just like normal I'm gonna do my
top 5 moments then list all the really
important references and takeaways I
could find and then do my review and
hello to any new people if you're just
finding me for the first time I do
weekly Doctor Who videos I even do a
weekly giveaway all you have to do to
enter that is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on this video on DeMaio's from
the episode if you haven't seen it yet
I'll wait just a sec okay ready here we
go top five moments number five Clara
and Danny Pink's dinner date it was a
nice reversal on the first time they met
only this time we were seeing it unfold
from Clara's perspective and we got to
see her apartment does anyone else get
the sense that Moffat is trying to play
a game and see how many funny places he
could park the TARDIS in series 8
Capaldi totally went up to himself by
parking it in her bedroom the kitchen
was funny but the bedroom was better
especially him looking into Clara's
vanity mirror that's like a whole other
conversation we could have about that
what was he thinking about while he was
waiting for her to come back I got this
vibe from the first episode whenever he
was talking to the robot about
forgetting who he was you know all about
identity and there was just so much
going on during that dinner date I just
loved the pacing Samuel Anderson turning
on a dime the way he reacted to the war
killings I totally expect that to be
paid off in a later episode and then we
have to think about the wells I feel
like there's an importance in that 23
number I've been telling everyone to
look at the planets in the opening title
sequence there is the one that looks
just like Gallifrey or post war trans
lore but in terms of quantity there are
about 27 planets which is the same
number that Davros and the Daleks hid in
the Medusa cascade I don't think there's
any kind of connection between Davros as
planets and Danny pink swells but I do
think it's an interesting coincidence
there was this moment when they paid off
the date later you know at the end when
Karl basically went back she commented
on the laws of time I took it as a
subtle dig at the classic doctors being
scolded by the Time Lords but I do
wonder what are the actual laws of time
if you can remember any old episodes or
anything from the classic doctor runs
where they quote laws of time just let
us know in the comments below but on to
number four Dan the soldier man
this was so trippy try not to overthink
it too much but this is where my mind
went
young Rupert is obsessed with the story
he's created for his army figure Dan the
soldier man then because of the courage
Clarke gives him in the doctors fantasy
dream
he's inception into joining the
real-life army one day so that he can
learn to be a hero in order to reaffirm
that he changes his name to that of his
childhood hero and he becomes Danny pink
later the war takes his toll and we meet
him at coal Hill School afterwards but
let's think about the actual story of
Dan the soldier man the story that
Rupert created he was destined to be a
leader but he didn't want to join said
army cut to misy collecting Souls or
soldiers or however you want to think
about it real quick though to finish the
sentence I'm gonna have to talk about
potential spoiler stuff so if you want
to you can just turn the volume down so
you see this boiler tag go away okay
ready
here we go what if Missy will create an
army of Cybermen and try to force Danny
to become the leader and he'll be like
the focal point of the doctor stopping
them just a new theory I thought of when
listening to the Dan the soldier man's
story okay spoiler part over on to
number three spaceman Danny pink his
name is Colonel Orson pink from a
hundred years in the future but there's
so much going on here too I guess our
children or grandchildren will be
pioneering time travel a hundred years
isn't that far away
his whole story though was just like a
self-contained thing I don't think there
was anything sinister about Orson but I
do wonder if we'll see him again
I feel like multiple Danny Pink's would
be a nice twist on the impossible girl
storyline I totally buy the argument
that his time capsule of malfunctioned
and sent him to the end of everything
the Robinson Crusoe metaphor was perfect
and it implied that the doctor will
eventually die a final death like he
won't be the last being living in the
universe that is unless he finds a way
to exist in the void outside of normal
space-time that's the crazy thing about
trying to apply logic to Doctor Who
there's always some timey wimey
workaround that will allow the doctor to
walk away with a few scratches in a new
face I don't think we got an exact date
on that into the universe time but what
Moffat was trying to apply you know
wasn't that the universe was ending our
time was ending I think he was just
trying to say that the universe had
reached a point in its expansion when
matter has started to drift apart so
planets didn't exist anymore
just because they'd been pulled apart if
you
never watched cosmos it's on Netflix
Neil deGrasse Tyson talks a lot about
what's happening to the universe as time
goes on its expansion is accelerating so
eventually all galaxies and planets and
everything will just drift apart until
there's no more gravity to hold
everything together
that's like billions of years away
though so Doctor Who science lesson over
you know essentially at the end of
things that Robinson Crusoe moment was
just when all the planets had drifted
apart but on to number two
the shared nightmare and the new monster
I love the idea of a universally shared
experience tied to a new type of monster
and yes I do think that the creatures
hiding under the beds were a new thing
that we haven't seen before if they've
been the silence they would have been
away taller and no I don't think that
Moffat ever intends to show us what they
look like I don't think he even knows
what they look like
I think the bed sheet is just meant to
represent what each of us pictures when
we think about something creeping under
the bed and I did get the sense that
they were trying to make a joke on the
doctor potentially being that creature
like things go missing strange noises
unexplained things happen and it's all
because the doctor is just jumping
around in space-time messing with things
it even got just a little bit creepy
until we saw the doctor take that sip of
coffee and you know then it turned into
a joke I always forget how good the
doctor is at pinching stuff I mean if he
can pinch the moment from underneath the
Timelords noses he could probably pin a
cup of coffee
speaking of thief that theme is gonna
continue into episode 5 which is called
time heist but my number-one moment
of course the stopover on Gallifrey I'll
admit I lost a little bit when this
happened I actually thought it was gonna
be some creepy barn that Clara was
forced to sleep in in case you missed it
though Clara's speech at the end of the
episode explained that the barn they
were in was the same barn where that
John Hurt doctor took the moment during
the 50th anniversary episode I know
there was like a little bit of confusion
whenever the 50th happened as to which
planet John Hurt was on whenever he was
walking through the sand everything I've
read about this episode says that barn
scene was on Gallifrey so unless
something weird was going on John Hurt
was also on Gallifrey during the 50th I
just love how Moffat used the moment to
book in the doctor's life you know tying
his greatest atrocity to his deepest
nightmare time really isn't meant to be
a circle like the scene implied it's
more like a river that Forks but Moffat
who actually did write the episode all
by himself gives us a lot of information
about the doctors true motivation he
has at all times since his first face as
the episode implies been driven by fear
and now thanks to the courage that Clara
gave him he's used that fear to become
the doctor to create that persona we
have to remember that doctor wasn't born
with that name he gave himself the name
the doctor maybe as a result of what
Clara told him you know I guess that's
what they were trying to apply I try not
to get too tied up in paradoxes and the
doctors timeline but I'd love the
thought that Clara is so fundamentally
tied to the doctors life like he would
not be the doctor if she had never
existed it makes your head spin a little
bit because you wonder how did things go
down the first time because Clara did
not exist before the doctor he
presumably found her
then the impossible girl storyline on
trenzalore happened cut too many Clara's
over his timeline then to child doctor
given courage to join the Time Lord
Academy by Clara
I feel like this scene more than any
other in series 8 is something we're
gonna be talking about for years but now
it's your turn let me know in the
comments what was your favorite moment
and where do you think this episode
ranks in terms of scary Doctor Who
episodes I wouldn't say it's like top 5
maybe at least top 20 here's a couple of
the bigger references and takeaways that
I noticed but please add any that you
saw in the comments so first off was the
title of the episode listen reminds you
a lot of the other one-word Doctor Who
episode titles and the fact that it was
a bit horror made me think of Blink
although I still think that Blanc is a
scarier episode and then there's hi that
was actually Clara's fourth episode
during 7b so we had a one-word title for
the fourth episode two series in a row
we'll have to see that trend continues
next year in series 9 moving on
to daytime every time I seek Laurent
Dani paint together the subject of Lady
killing comes up it sounds like they
might pay that off in the finale I mean
I hope they do otherwise why would they
bring that up every time they're
together
moving to Frankenstein's laboratory the
telepathic link in the TARDIS it
reminded me of something right out of
Frankenstein especially with the
steampunky look of the console in the
rest of the room the new TARDIS is like
a loaf I sinister-looking Frankenstein
laboratory we can only imagine what kind
of creature he's going to create in
there moving on to the children's home
this was the first time that I've seen
Capaldi use psychic paper in series 8
I'm totally glad to see it back I
remember there was an instance where
Matt Smith showed off an ID badge and it
actually had a picture of the first
doctor in it so now every time whenever
the doctor flashes his
psychic paper is like an ID I wonder if
it's the first doctors picture that
people are seeing here in Rupert or
Danny's bedroom that robot that the
doctors holding looks just like the
robot from Tom Baker's first episode
this box of soldiers here - just makes
me hallucinate Cybermen I feel like the
story of Dan the soldier man is
definitely going to be involved in the
finale here when they get to the end of
everything and the doctors going on
about silence it actually made me think
of the silences prophecy silence will
fall when the first question is asked
now the creatures were not the silence
but it makes me think that the silences
prophecy might carry forward into series
8 overall I felt like this episode was
just the strongest in series 8
definitely my new favorite I gave it a
solid 8 plus it didn't linger too long
on affectation during the date scene and
because Moffat has this crazy Doctor Who
mind Palace and he wrote the episode by
himself the story served as this huge
book end for the doctors existence think
about it this way Clara helped the
doctor so that he could grow up to
become the doctor safer so that he could
help her help himself I also really love
the way that Danny pink is becoming a
part of the team without even knowing it
like his timeline is now fundamentally
linked to Clara and the doctors this all
feels like setup for a huge Danny pink
moment in the finale and the idea that
fear will take you home to feel so much
more important now like the doctors fear
Missy's fear claws fear and so on will
be the connective tissue of series 8 in
general behind the scenes I actually
heard there's a lot of drama going on
with the Doctor Who production you know
between the producers and Moffat and for
whatever reason Moffat is just like
dominating series 8 stories I don't know
if that's true but I definitely feel
like the episodes that are directly
connected to the big Missy plot will
benefit from Moffitt's direct
involvement so with that in mind here
are some of the other episodes Moffat is
listed as writer on there's episode five
time heist that's next week
episode 6 the caretaker in two weeks and
then there's the final two episodes
eleven and twelve
dark water and death in heaven
respectively so I'd expect those
episodes will directly tie in with the
Missy plot so just to talk about the
actors a little bit I feel like Capaldi
was fantastic in this episode I love
watching him lecture himself Samuel
Anderson is starting to come into his
own - I loved the alternate version of
Danny pink he created although
technically it was his grandson but I
loved the eye
of an impossible Danny's storyline just
like an impossible para storyline it
also kind of makes you wonder if there's
gonna be some sort of Cyberman tie in
with like Danny pink Cybermen and Oz
went Dalek they both into becoming these
horrible things in their timeline let's
not forget that the doctor's companions
usually meet some sort of untimely end
but move along my next Doctor Who video
is gonna be my top 5 scary episodes be
sure to subscribe to get that I'll be
posting that tonight and then my queue
day is gonna post tomorrow so be sure to
leave all your questions about the
stopover on Gallifrey the Missy plot
anything else you want me to include on
so the giveaway winner whenever I post
that queue a so lots of stuff coming
tonight you can click here to get the
bonus video and click here to get the
Q&A I'll add the annotations as soon as
I post those videos thank you so much
for watching I'll see you guys tonight
high fives
you